just give us your general thoughts on
kind of where we're headed for the next
three six nine months kind of seeing
everything in the market structure not
necessarily price wise but you're just
what you're seeing kind of on chain and
your overall feeling yeah so i mean i
would really love um honestly i think
just some more consolidation as as
managing as it is for some that want to
see us go parabolic um i think just from
kind of we're seeing on chain from the
derivative side of things where uh
traders keep getting ahead of themselves
i think due for some for some choppiness
i think a lot of the speculators would
be it'd be great if if they left the
market and you know i'm not not hoping
anybody leaves or gets burned but um i
think some some boredom would do us good
uh and i honestly think the next kind of
bullish catalyst is is you're gonna see
the fed try to hike they're going to try
to taper their asset purchases
and just off of you know going off
historical precedent over the last you
know really 20 years anytime the fed has
tried to pull back
the stimulus pull back the punch bowl it
blows up in their face and i i don't
think this time is different at all and
so i think that's that's really when you
see bitcoin just explode is when you
know the the taper the
the you know rate heights
just blow up in their face and that's
when bitcoin is is gonna get bid
probably similar to march of 2020 when
when everything sells off and then
bitcoin recovers first and then
outperforms everything i would i would
imagine that uh would repeat again and
so that's kind of my sentiment over the
next uh really year or so i mean however
long the timeline takes i think i think
bitcoin is more of a macro asset than
ever and i think that's really bullish
gotcha dylan i've seen some charts
recently about just like the general
market of the s p 500 and bitcoin and
the correlation with that what do you
think around bitcoin being correlated to
other assets or in general to the
overall market structure
yeah i mean that's a great point uh
bitcoin increasingly as it grows in
market cap is is just a function i i
believe of um the liquidity of the kind
of the everything bubble um you know
in in traders terms bitcoin is just a
high beta risk asset and over the short
to medium term time frames i that is
true right in march of 2020 when bitcoin
uh sold off really first it it almost
front ran everything selling off uh it
bottomed before everything else people
said bitcoin the bitcoin experiment
failed it's not recession proof it's not
it's not a hedge it's not a
diversification and when in reality pop
i actually remember you having a great
post about this it was just a liquidity
crunch the dollar got bit and so i think
i think that's what you're really seeing
is that um in the everything bubble
everything's going to go up and then if
credit contracts everything goes down
and really the outperformers are are you
know kind of the reaction when they when
they respond to to the bust and so um i
think that that's unchanged and bitcoin
will will draw down if equities go down
20 and that's a good thing
because they're going to have to
reinflate everything just with you know
the political incentives and everything
else and so um you know over the short
to medium term volatility or
correlations to other risk assets don't
disprove uh the kind of the bitcoin
thesis that it's the best money the
world has ever seen it just kind of
reinforces how uh overextended how far
gone we are in this kind of fiat credit
everything bubble
yeah i i think that uh what you're
specifically referring to is in march of
2020 uh i literally wrote the piece and
it was like explaining what liquidity
crises are and i went back and i looked
at the 2008-2009 global financial crisis
and i was like hey look when people get
scared when there's uncertainty when
there's uh some sort of fear in the
market uh they end up selling their
assets and they go for the dollar they
want security and so like we're in a
liquidity crisis don't be uh you know um
kind of short-term thinker understand
what's happening uh prices may go down
you know more but ultimately the
liquidity crisis does get solved
especially if the government steps in
and then that day bitcoin fell 50
and i gotta say even though i you know
uh conceptually understood what was
happening uh it still doesn't feel good
right you know you buy after like the 20
down but it goes down another 20 you're
like okay cool like you know i'm a
genius that goes down more like dude
what is this going you know how low is
this thing going and uh is this maybe
not a liquidity crisis but are we
watching it go to zero uh and you know
obviously uh the uh what i call the fear
buys ended up being uh pretty good but
uh but it's crazy you know even when you
know that uh this is how liquidity
crisis work they still don't feel good
for you know anyone uh who's uh living
through it right
yeah exactly i think that's that's why
it's also important to not uh be
overexposed i mean you can i'm i think
we're we're all extremely bullish on
bitcoin but even having uh you know 2x
leverage on your bitcoin position right
where if you're allocated to bitcoin
with 200 of your net worth is is pretty
dangerous right because these these
events can occur right bitcoin was on a
saturday night two weeks ago it was down
20
uh right like these things are gonna
happen again whether it's uh natively in
bitcoin with the derivatives market or
the macro uncertainty causes bitcoin to
completely unwind and it kind of
cascades on each other right so um you
know always having that pristine
collateral the bitcoin that you're
stacking um if that event occurs then
you can take advantage of that
increasingly so with you know the
ability to collateralize your stack get
fiat liquidity all these things uh
bitcoins increasing like
financialization it's actually an ad
positive uh but you never want to leave
you you know you never want to become a
force seller in one of these events it's
the worst thing you can do
and so i think that's just important to
say